now the killing of George Floyd who
would have been 47 years old today
shocked America and sparked Nationwide
protests against police brutality five
months on and his son Quincy has told
Sky News he can't stop watching the
footage of his father's last moments
alive he's also spoken about the
grieving process with Neville Lawrence
the father of Steven Lawrence who is
murdered in a racist attack in southeast
London although 27 years separate their
deaths of their loved ones they are
united in the fight against racial
Injustice as skyn Phillips now reports
just a warning the report contains some
flash
photography kneeling on the Street in
Minneapolis where his father George
Floyd took his last breath is a pain
that is deeply personal for his eldest
son Quincy his father was killed when a
police officer knelt on his neck for 8
minutes and 46 seconds I can't stop
watching the video I watch the video
almost over and over not every day but
every now and and I just think about him
it's the sort of grief Neville Lawrence
knows all too well we've brought the two
men together for the first time when I
saw the incident with your dad being
kneeling on on the floor with that man
kneeling on his neck and the other
officers around standing and watching
tears came out my
eyes like George Floyd Steven Lawrence's
racist killing 20 7 years ago has left
an indelible Mark in British Society how
did you get through the the tragedy of
happen what happened to your son um we
had to go into
counseling the old family had to go into
counseling and and talk about it even
now really right now you know if I went
to if I went to a funeral to see
somebody being
buried I can't go near when they put in
the per the the off and down I can't go
near
it because I'm looking and thinking that
I'm reburying Steven
again
gra in the off map of his death America
was left in turmoil George Floyd's name
echoed across the world I remember
watching your dad's funeral on TV and
seeing just how emotional and just how
raw it was for your family can you
describe what it was like for you it's
like you see him
breathing my knees is kind of
buckle I kiss him in the forehead let
him know that everything's going to be
all right your son's going to be here
with you your family's here with
you you're not going to go out in
vain and we would to go bury
him Queen quiny now drives the Cadillac
which George Floyd once owned he's also
launched a memorial project in his
hometown to honor his dad's Legacy what
is it like for you when you hear those
words I can't breathe the knee on his
neck say he could breathe and call off
Mama it's
devastating and I have sheld just
thinking about what he was saying it's
not going to be very easy and and and
for for all the years that I've been
struggling it hasn't been easy but you
have to have um a h in View and the H in
view of my family was to try and get
Justice it took us a long time but
eventually we got some justice and you
can't give up you know you got to keep
fighting in 2012 two men were finally
jailed for life for the racist murder of
Neville's
son I have part time trusting any cops
right about
now am I saying all cops of bad
cops all cops not good
cops but s have to my father they said
me not trust any cop George Floyd's
death was a painful reminder of
America's troubled history of racism and
police
brutality 3,000 Mi apart these two men
are united in their fight demanding
nothing less than racial Justice no
Phillips Sky News